good yeah thnkx actually was one of the
organizers I wasn't planning to topple
last week we have much better speakers
who are all who was supposed to come but
Petros told me last week well that
speaker is not coming can you talk so of
course I didn't have enough time to
prove new results so I have to brush up
on old ones but this morning we also
itõs not here yet so we are switching
once more luckily when Petro cerritos
not here I was afraid you'll say you
have to be both talks but not only one
talk I don't know what happens the
afternoon we'll announce it will
announce it as it's 12 goats right ok so
I'm going to talk about tents as an
optimization some of you perhaps have
heard this as I said this is not some of
it I mean hopefully it'll be new to some
of you but also hopefully you the others
were referred this or forgotten what it
is so I want to start with so normally
in people working in numerical methods
no tensors or everybody knows what
tensors are tensors are just going to be
instead of two-dimensional arrays with
your matrices three four five whatever
number of dimensions dimensional arrays
right in the talk I'll often focus on
three dimensional arrays because the
notation gets were ended otherwise but
all that i'm going to say will extend to
our dimensional arrays with the catch
that the complexity will grow
exponentially not ok so that's something
you cannot avoid now the numerical part
of it people are used to tensors as sets
of numbers and so on I want to connect
it up in the spirit of this workshop or
the semester I want to connect it up
with discrete algorithms or with what
goes on in TCS and for that reason I'm
going to start off with a couple of
classes of discrete problems
combinatorial problems which can be
reduced to tens of problems and then
focus on tensor problems right that's
what I'm going to do so the first
problem I want to oh ok sorry look
that's the wrong side I guess
yeah the first problem I want to attack
I want to look at is in general max are
set I'm going to look at max three set
max three set has clauses each clause
looks like that three variables with
three stands for 3 right X I bar X jxk I
mean this is obviously said to be true
if either X is false because there's a
bar there or XJR XD is true if one of
those options happens then it's set to
true otherwise false the satisfiability
problem you want to satisfy all the
clauses the mac satisfiability problem
is a little more gentle you have to
satisfy as many clauses as possible
you're given a list of three clauses on
n variables find an assignment
satisfying the maximum number of
clusters well known our problem and so
on what does this have to do with 10
says we will see on this slide I'm going
to reduce it to a tensor problem by
setting up eight three tenses 8 n by N
by n tenses a1 through AI where a1 I JK
the idea Kate entry is the number of
causes that get satisfied if you have
the assignment X I xjx k all equal to
one if I set them all to one there are
eight possible assignments for three
variables if I set them all to one that
assignment makes there may be many such
clauses makes many such clauses whatever
number of clauses to be true a 2 is a
similar thing you enumerate all a things
so 011 setting of these three variables
sets these clauses to be true so each
Clause will contribute not just 21 tents
little contribute to seven tenses right
all but one which sets it to be false I
don't expect that you need to check all
the details but just believe me this is
what and then you can reformulate this
problem just as a tensor maximization
problem maximize these so now the tensor
problems will consider or of the form a
i j k door three tenses or three
subscript xixj xk i want to maximize
this the second tensei has a 1 minus x I
because of the X I bar that right and so
on does the eight of these and I want to
maximize the sum
well this again by a leap of faith I
won't tell you but it can be done for
all' max or constraint satisfaction
problems again you're familiar with that
that's fine otherwise just think of
satisfiability constraint satisfaction
problems and you get to to the art
tenses to to the 38 tenses here you get
to to the our chances now for this talk
for this talk I will only focus on
articles 3 just because the notation
gets for Ender's of the wife so no more
max es vivir only will look at tensile
optimization I've done the reduction I
assume the next problem i'm going to
talk about i'll talk about reducing two
or three problems over the top the next
problem i'm going to talk about is the
planted click problem which again many
of you are familiar with but let me
mention it you have a random graph GM
half that means n vertices each edge is
independently in with probability half
not there with probability half right
and I take the graph I add to it a
clique of size p I plant a clique clique
of size speed on top of that and I'm
given i'm giving you the whole thing I
don't tell you which the what the click
is and your job is to find Italy that's
called a hidden clique problem or the
plaintiff clique problem it's been
studied a lot just because it seemed
when people formulated it to be quite
easy but we haven't solved it for
perhaps a decade or more right so if P
is it's known that if P is at least root
n then you can solve it by spectral
methods I won't describe them but alone
cover division silikov showed that a big
open question as I said it's got bigger
over time because we are not able to
solve it a big open question is to
reduce the exponent to to find lesser
size planted links so here is a tensor
idea the idea is I'm defining a 310 sir
n by N by n array which will have a
plus-one in d ijk entry if the following
happened I take the gravity I look at
three pairs i j j kk l among those three
pairs there are some edges and there are
some non edges right it's between 0 & 3
2 count if the
well of edges is all I put a plus one in
the tensor in that spot if the number of
edges is even I put a minus so parity
but this is a real tension it's not a
mod 2 or anything it's a real number
right plus or minus 1 and the theorem
that Allan Friesen I proved is the
following if you maximize this tensor
over unit length vectors Euclidean
length unit unit length vectors if you
can maximize that even within constant
factors you can find plaintiff gleeks
down to enter the one foot instrumental
one house ok so this requires the proof
is not this this proof is not that
simple it requires some work but once we
prove this we said ok now we should be
able to solve this problem in about
three days it's been about eight years
we have not been able to solve their
problem so it still remains only a half
result in that if you can find this then
in fact you can find the plaintiff
clique of size n to the one third and a
little later brubacher impala showed
that if you can solve the corresponding
are tens a problem I won't put this down
but it's just a parity of a number of
edges on the r sub graph if you can
solve there are tens a problem then get
you can find plenty to exercise n to the
1 over R now this is not the worst case
tensor optimization right this problem
this is more or less a random tensor it
came from a random graph more or less
plus so plentifully even then you're not
able to solve it now here's a problem
and again I'm sort of making this is a
problem which is on my to-do list and
I've never had time to study it but it's
an interesting problem again in the
spirit of this semester and and so on
it's a combination it's a continuous
version of this sort of discrete problem
i will call this the planted gaussian
problem here you have an n-by-n matrix
of iid normal 0 1 entries and i'm
planting a p by p sub matrix be with
normal new one it's biased it's muse
positive let's say so you these entries
are biased here in the B sub me this I
don't tell you what B is and I'm giving
you a plus B
must find be okay so let's call this a
planet of Gaussian problem more or less
the same arguments as a spectral methods
work when P times mu is greater than or
equal to order routine now the question
is can be get an advantage out of the
planted Gaussian for the plaintiff
Gaussian problem by reducing it to
tensors in a similar way can be done
solid of course which would be the
bigger question more generally planted
dense sub graph problems where it's not
a click but a dense sub graph have now
been studied quite a bit I will be
interesting to see tensor formulations
of those so now I'm done so far with
reducing combinatorial problems two
tensors for now later I might reduce
some other problem if there is time but
now i'm going to talk about tensor
optimization so here's a problem you'd
like to solve ideally right the problem
is we want to maximize a i j k YY j YK
where there are some other constraints
which of the form y I of 0 1 is what
happened for the max reset and but have
some of the y i's must be 1 minus some
of the other wires these are constraints
because you had X I and X Y bar right
xin one might excite so we have a bunch
of these constraints we want to maximize
this kind of bulky is this kind of cubic
function for three tenses and so on
let's say I introduce a little rotation
we think of the tensor a as operating on
the vectors X Y Z and that's just as
some I JK x I a I JK x iy jzk right if
there were only x and y and the matrix
you would have x transpose a why it's a
number just they operate this operates
on these vectors give you a number and
you want to maximize certain weight now
here is the scheme to try to do this
maximization suppose for the moment we
can approximate a by a simpler to
optimize now by simpler to optimize in
this context i'm going to be in low rank
you may wonder what the rank of a tensor
is we'll come to that in a minute but
it's like low rank matrices suppose we
can approximate a x is simpler to
optimize tensor be why is it simpler
we'll also see later so so that the
following is true you take the error in
the approximation of a by V that error
is maximized overall the maximum overall
unit length vectors of this right that
is just respectful all right if a and B
are matrices this is what you know as
the spectral lon vay minus B let's just
call that the spectral law spectral mom
I'll write with just a norm with no
subscript suppose that is less than
Delta so suppose I can do the
approximation and later we'll see we can
do it suppose we can do the
approximation so the spectral norm of
the error is at most Delta then solving
the problem with B instead of eight that
is solving this problem with be there
instead of a ensures the error is that
most well spectral norm if they were
unit length vectors you've got to scale
up by the length of these now I'm not
going to sit down and reckon the error
or here that's technical but all i want
to say here is the following we this
slide tells you the model of this slide
is it's enough to approximate a by a bee
the approximation should be good in
spectral long that's the norm we want
that is we want this a minus B to be
small not some other month there be
another normal comes up frobenius norm
namely sum of squares of all the entries
this is much smaller than that but it's
enough that this norm be small in the
approximation yeah
the equilibrium know it clear in no
manner yes so 401 vectors these will all
be root and each at most XP site
contains will not exist for this talk I
mean there's a way to take care of them
but it's only technical but so i'll
ignore it for this talk right i mean so
forget the side constraints just want to
do the optimization so this slide is
going to justify what I said in the last
night it's going to tell you that indeed
every cancer can be approximated you
will all seen well in fact i will show
you how tenses are very hard for this
talk forget that i want to tell you why
Tinsel's it easy right that's the
purpose of this talk so any chance I can
be approximated so here's annotation X
outer product Y outer products that is a
tensor with entries xiy Jay Z K so this
is an N by N by n tensor right and cubed
entry sneezes engines we call it a rank
1 tensor just an analogy with van [ __ ]
matrices and we introduce another norm
which is the sum of squares of all day
tree sofa beanie aslam right here's a
little lemma any are tender we did three
tensile so for any art answer for any
our tensor there are 1 over epsilon
square Rank 1 tenses whose some
approximates a well so in the sense the
spectral norm of the difference is that
most epsilon times the Frobenius norm of
it that's your approximation we get now
dilemma shouldn't look mysterious
because here is the proof this is very
simple okay so here's here's a lemma
right you start with B equals zero right
that you're first starting approximation
if lemma is already satisfied you go
home if it's not satisfied there are x
y&z so that so a minus B has high
spectral norm if it's not satisfied if
it has high spectral norm by definition
there are x y&z so that this is true
spectral norm is too high take that x
y&z times a particular
strength and subtracted that's your next
rank 1 tensor you subtract it and
happily go on and it's simple to prove
that you will end with this
approximation this is just the imitation
of the greedy algorithm for SVD which we
know works for the SVD optimally here
it's not optimal but it still satisfies
this at the end of the day and you can
prove that they gained the proof is not
very difficult okay that's well all very
good but we want algorithms right now to
get an algorithm to make this
constructive we need to find the XYZ in
the case that the lemma is not already
satisfied thats we need to find the XYZ
to to to maximize the spectral norm and
in a paper whose title is telling it
says that most tensor problem very hard
indeed they are Hiller and Limp proved
for instance so that is hard you cannot
even for three tenses maximize the
spectral one okay so what do we do now
well this is jointless joint work with
de la Vega karpinski and then Paula said
this is a bit old now but I haven't had
time to prove new results because i only
knew i had to give a talk last week but
here's the result and this is what i'll
describe briefly we proved that for any
art answer r if you give me an extra
factor of four instead of the one
they're right then in fact i can find it
that is i can do this in time polynomial
provided epsilon is constant for every
concept salon you can in fact find the
approximation in time which is
polynomial right and one remark here
worth making we cannot it would be much
nicer if they this result i can put for
Venus from here all spectral norm there
and I cannot it's very simple to see
that you cannot do it this is the best
we can do but I already justified their
spectral norm approximations you know so
i will describe this i think in a couple
of slides started at eleven-fifteen
right you started at live at 15 right
learnt okay so I think we're fine I mean
I there you for the audience sake I
always adopt a program where there's a
denominator and the number of slides
it's something that you might keep
looking at because it helps you write
really livens I want to a six of the
five of the Living slides ok so the
central problem is this spectral norm at
maximization we want to find X Y is a
unit vector so that we want to maximize
this again with respect to this question
I throw away your site constraints they
don't really matter actually this it's
enough to solve this now observe that if
I knew the optimizing y and z so here's
a problem if I knew that if somebody
somebody luckily told you what the best
y&z where then the corresponding X 2
optimizes is easy to find why is that
because i can plug the wine red into the
tens like if the tensile can operate on
the y and z so the sort of matlab ish
notation if you will and this gives you
a vector right if I hit it with three
vectors x y&z I get a number they hear
the two vectors I get a vector and that
vector tells you what X should be
because I take the dot product of that
vector is X to get this right that's all
I'm doing this requires a little I mean
it should seem natural requires a little
bit of work to just check that automatic
but that's otherwise it's fine so if
somebody told me why ends that I know
the X so in some sense the problem is
one-third solved it's reduced to I sorry
it's reduced to two thirds of the
problem because if out of the three if I
told you I until I can find X right so
now I see I want to find this quantity
this some sorry the right-hand side but
to do that I need although all the Y's
inside and I need to do this exact thing
but I don't have to do it exactly I can
estimate it if I have just a few tips so
I don't have all of these n squared
terms right for each other and sweetums
but let's say I have a few then I can
try to estimate this but the important
question is how do we make sure the
variance of the estimate is not too high
the entries the way we have no control
over they can be anything okay so it
turns out lengths plate sampling words
and the next slide I tell you in little
more
tell what this is that means the
following even if I estimate this I
still don't know X but I tried this
estimate for several candidate y&z and
each candidate wins that gives me a
candidate x I have to try them all out
how do we know which Candida X is the
best well we checked once we have an X
on hand full x all the end there mmm
components then i plug the xn and then
into into this thing now I a problem
with just Y's and Z's are unknowns but
that's an SPD problem okay I started by
saying if I knew why and said I know X
now I'm saying if I know actually I can
find y and z because that's an SVD
that's one less one less arity tensor
problem so i can solve that and here's
one more flight of detail on this
algorithm so what I want to do then is
estimate this sum as y&z some doubt they
don't they don't appear in the output
only I is the variable here right but
really I want to estimate the sum for
all possible Y in Tibet because I don't
know which the optimizing lions at all
so I pic so i can't do the whole some i
want to estimate it i pick a certain
subset of JK a constant number of pairs
JK and I picked them in iid trials with
probability proportional to the length
squared this is the probability that you
heard in the first few talks as well
that is I take the sum over I so sum
over the whole fiber or the whole line
of ajk a i j k squared it should be
excuse me there should be an i there I
guess anyway you can't see from a
distance there might have been an i and
you missed it anyway so that they should
have been tonight so a i j k squared
divided by that what is that don't worry
about the number i want to pick a JK
with poverty proportional to sum of
squares everybody on the line about it
and for each such JK we still don't know
y and z even if I to do the sum I picked
us I said estimated by a subsample but I
don't know why I'm said but I just now
enumerate all possible values of Y exit
I can do that because there are only a
constant number of them and therefore
their only is many values once having
done that I find this guy that's an
estimate of what I wanted that tells me
that tells me what X should be and
that's I take that X i plug it back in
into y and z I'm sorry if I didn't if
you didn't follow all the details but
the idea is just sampling does the job
and it turns out that with this length
squared sampling you get variance to be
bounded that requires a bit of work to
do to bound the variance but you can in
fact do that now for what so okay so we
did I I said there's no free lunch
excuse me let me just go back one slide
so we get this kind of error where where
here's a spectral norm here is for be
Nia small the Frobenius norm in general
is much larger than the spectrum so you
can ask why is this any good right and
it turns out it's good enough to solve
the constraint satisfaction problems we
want to solve several of them so first
let's do two CS fields for three CSV max
2sat that's already and be hard to do it
exactly or max cut which is also a to
CSP I won't show you the reduction but
it's well known so let's say there are n
variables in the case of grass that's n
vertices and m is the number of clauses
for the sad problem or the number of
edges for the graph problem then the
Frobenius norm of a is the sum of
squares of all the injuries if there are
M once it's it's am but the error in our
approximation is a spectral norm of a
minus B times all these guys and again
to answer this question x + 1 minus X
are at most root n there are 0 1 vectors
you playin almost it moves root n times
this and if you work this out you get
this that's the error you can get but
you cannot afford an error of more than
M because for instance max at max cut
you can solve two constant times n very
simply by
choosing edges of random for instance or
better right so we cannot afford to not
edit or more than am so this better be
less than M and that if you workout
tells you that M should be at least n
squared square of the number of Ages
that's for dense graphs so in fact this
works for dense csps as well dense max
three-set where there are n cubed
closest right or if you're full site
into the four claws or the ends of the
four clauses so we are going to now so
i'm going to show you now that in fact
you can do a larger class of problems a
class above their interests that
includes some interesting thing like
metrics in the case of two in the case
of two tensors matrices and analogous
thing for tensors higher we'll see but
first for matrices just focus on
matrices i'm going to show you that
matrix as well as dense problems can be
taken care of by this so what our matrix
matrix just means that triangle
inequality is satisfied right you take
an entry it's at most the sum of the two
entries I jjk and ik right I won't tell
you i will put down the triangle
inequality let's say that di is the sum
of the row in the eye i throw the matrix
a now a matrix and it's a degree if its
adjacency matrix the graph G I is just a
degree here's a normalization that's
useful in many contexts if you have a
matrix a you can normalize it by
dividing by square root of didj this is
useful in clustering and Markov chains
and a lot of context it turns out this
scaling doesn't quite do the job for us
here's a more robust and better scaling
again this is potentially useful in
other contexts similar context as well
that is you take the average degree
let's say it as VI divided by n sum of
di development let's see total number of
edges / 2 she would have it so graph and
i scaled by the square root not of di x
DJ di plus v bar plus pj times V Bar
sorry x DJ times d bar so add the
average degree to both of these terms
the advantage of this is that here if
the degree is very small this entry
blows up
but this does not look even if the
degree small it's modulated by the
average degree and that turns out to be
quite useful and we call a cold dense
this is the word that we made up for our
paper it's called accordant if the
Frobenius norm of B sum of squares are
all the increase is constant why do we
do that well first of all it turns out
this is the common generalization of
dense matrices as well as metrics and
several other things even powers of
matrix they are all codecs so that to
show that metrics are co dense requires
a couple of lines of proof but it's not
that difficult but dense matrices it's
easy to see if a matrix is dense the
average degrees n right so I'm dividing
by square root of n times n which is N
and the Frobenius norm is dividing it by
n squared because i'm squaring it once
more so i take 1 over n straight summed
over all entry such at most of a
constant it's not important that you
follow the technical check but just to
want to mention that dense matrices are
those metrics and other things are
covered by this and putting this all
together it turns out we can get
polynomial time approximation schemes
for all code dense max or CSP problems
that's the end result of all this that
is you can get within 1 plus epsilon
relative error for any epsilon in
polynomial time for all of these
problems right which include dense as
well as matrix and other things now
that's all I'll say about this result
now I want to also tell you another
another class of tensors that come up
have come up earlier have keep coming up
in more recent work as well so those are
moment tensors so if you have a random
variable if you have a set of random
variables x1 to xn which have some
mutual dependence right we expected
value zero let's say they are centered
so that they expected value of each x is
0 you all know that the variance
covariance matrix is just this
particular matrix so
i J is the expected value of x I XJ
that's called the variance covariance
matrix that plays a big role in
statistics you could just as well
defined also third moment tensor that is
you take a make an array a i j k whose
expectation who's ijk entry is
expectation of XIX GX ko4 x is fourth
moments and so on now if you wanted to
compute for a unit vector U or any
vector u u dot X cubed the expected
value you you can convince yourself that
is simply just the tensor a operating on
you you you that's pretty standard now
so it turns out that optimizing for
Kansas can be done in some context and
that's actually pretty useful so here's
one context I'll refer to so if the
expected value of x is 0 which we assume
and the ex I of four-way independent so
there's some dependence between them but
they are four-way independent and our is
some orthonormal transformation then
even the local Maxima so I like to
maximize this function globally that we
don't know how to do but even the local
Maxima of this function that is i take u
transpose RX that's a scalar to the
fourth power I maximize it with a unit
ball the local Maxima give you the Rose
of our inverse basically ignore this
condition now why is this any voices of
interest it turns out I actually want
discuss this here but clearly many of
you will be familiar with the subject
call independent component analysis this
is so we were able to show actually
basically independent component analysis
can be done and this is a very so this
lemma is very simple it's not very
difficult so this lemma is actually at
the heart of showing that you can in
fact finders are and therefore do it
dependent upon analysis there are many
extensions of this but the remark I want
to make here is some random the model of
this is some random tenses or easy to
optimize like this one is here the local
local maximum actually give you global
Maxima minima this won't always happened
but
can happen is what this is saying and
more recently actually there have been
users of this generalizations and users
of this sense perhaps most recently and
Kumar shoe and Kaka day use third moment
tenses not using any of this but in a
different way using third moment tensors
they were able to do something about
topic modeling and I want to finish this
is the last slide I want to finish with
I call this the epilogue he's a more
recent results obviously this is
something I would have had more to say
but for the fact that we only got the
paper last week so there are now results
of your she turns out this year that
what I said for a subset of cord ends
problems can be done by a totally
different method using going up the
what's called a share aliens hierarchy a
few levels now it would be nice and i
think the authors are thinking about
this trying to give new pluses for which
this would work besides go dance and
that's something that's ongoing and i
don't have much to say about this only
because it's very recent as i said the
method is completely different now
another little thing i want to mention
the epilogue without detail is the
following a loner approximation of
tensors automatically corresponds to
something about polynomials and our
tensor a you can think of as a ha are
homogeneous polynomial where you take a
i j k there's only a three tensor is
three homogeneous a i j k xixj xk that's
a polynomial in the variables x1 through
xn cubic three homogeneous polynomial a
rank 1 tensor in the setting easily seem
to approximate the product of three
polymers which are linear a dot X B dot
X 0 X right these are linear polynomials
so in some sense this result i already
showed you the lemma even says that any
homogeneous polynomial can be
approximated by a sum of small number of
products of linear polynomial now let's
driver has a much stronger result and
again I probably won't described as that
except
perhaps piqued your curiosity you can go
look at the paper by Lex now here's a
would be a nice thing to do which I
don't know how to do but so tensors
right or cubic forms or multi linear
forms are generalizations of quadratic
forms so we know that optimizing
quadratic forms like semi definite
programming is useful to solve common
tool optimization problems like Max card
or max at and so on to a certain orders
to certain area thresholds assume now
for the moment and that we don't know
how to do this assume now for the moment
that you can do tensor optimization
spectral norm or three tenses to within
1 plus epsilon factors for any constant
that for now I told you that they were
hardness results but those hardness
results don't rule out this possibility
that there exists algorithms like this I
don't know how to do this for worst-case
sensors we don't know it was even for
random tenses because if we could then
planted click type problems would be
solvable but let's assume this and then
can one beat the approximation factor
for let's say Mac skype or max at that
be interesting to do so some a
utilization of higher order methods than
quadratic methods for solving mokama
torial problems without I stop this is
my last fight we've got the denominator
numerator equal
yes it doesn't so oh good good point so
in defining the tensor from the
plaintiff click I said one for parity
odd parity minus 1 4 u infinity the
question is why don't they put one if
there's a triangle 0 if there is no
triangle we tried several variations
like that for the tensor we cannot prove
anything about those variations namely
we cannot prove that optimizing the
cubic form does the job for you so the
point is okay so very briefly right so
it is true that the planted part gives
you high values of cubical but you have
to prove that the big random part does
not give you a higher value and for that
you apply to random matrix theory we're
gonna type them but those things are not
necessarily true when you put in so it's
not being that type theorem because you
have gone to attend sir there's
dependence so we actually have to have
an epsilon net argument but that is on
an argument or even big no type results
don't work unless you have plus minus
one random well they may work in other
cases but that's the only case where we
know it works but yes what I'm to try
other tenses but you don't know how to
make them work
yeah so do i believe the unique games
conjecture is true that's another talk
let's not worry about